this is for me
yeah I guess really there's no more for
me back there
oh okay
and Lord knows this will be something
wait that's for me yeah okay okay
no it's not it's
fire right it looks like a racing suit
and I see my name on it but I know this
is gonna be something brutal
laughs
[Laughter]
let's see oh yeah that's on there yeah
oh yeah
double stitched now how are you gonna
feel when I take this out to the track
immediately
will you see me on the [ __ ] pavement
tomorrow FaceTime me dude I'll be on the
water
on the board dude this suit is insane
who made this it's sick right
this is badass yeah
yeah this is hard as hell I might just
wear this yeah I was like it has to be a
good one with the face
got me a real board yeah so I had to get
you a wrist this is sick dude thank you
yeah no problem I got you a little some
did you yeah
you know I know you like your treats
what the [ __ ] is is that
so I got you a snow cone maker like dude
how hell yeah sorry
yeah don't break it
but uh yeah you know you're making a lot
of snow jokes so ah yeah okay nice you
will need some snow for it though
uh and I got you I got you right here
[Laughter]
laughs
that's that pure
that's that beer right there
some of that right
there
are you good
Is that real
I don't know let's find out
oh whoa
all right
[Laughter]
movie movie cocaine [ __ ] I don't know
dude let's run
I'm just gonna I'm not gonna snort it
I'm just gonna smell it yeah yeah
what is that
Xylitol or whatever
that's pure
that's pure it's cocaine is what it is
yeah let me just get a little
so funny every week we're like we gotta
do something about getting demonetized
every single week yeah
and then
like and then we do this that's a
nositol it's fake a nose at all that's
what it is but my my nose feels funny
now
yeah my nose is tall
kind of an ironic thing that fake
cocaine is has nose in it seriously yeah
dude totally man I've never thought
about that one yeah holy [ __ ] dude so
dude I think like we should start a
company
yeah for inositol yeah not enough people
know about it yeah for sure
also there's a massive deer problem in
like all of America yeah and no one's
killing them
yeah you ever played deer pong no oh
dude let's play around
I needed to get I feel bad now I didn't
get a real gift that's a real gift this
is a real gift yeah I mean you can
actually take that home and use it yeah
my nose actually feels weird now
have you ever snorted that stuff before
not a nose at all yeah okay
what does it feel like
it's actually it's actually doing
cocaine powdered Tylenol actually
you just did you just did way too much
Tylenol
my head feels really good though
this is this is the best Christmas ever
we got a bunch of good [ __ ]
cookbook my new favorite shirt cocaine
uh a stroke trainer
lobsters that we were able to rip in
half yeah guilt-free yep yeah guilt-free
Lobster riffing yeah we found a way yeah
I think that could be one of my favorite
gifts right there
yeah where did this thing come from yeah
I wanna I wanna like just [ __ ] oh oh
I just tasted more of it
and
tastes bad my throat's dumb yeah
oh we
okay come on in
come on in
oh my God
a Red-Nosed Reindeer
[Music]
games wow
[Music]
hey
[Music]
is that because red nose because of the
yeah it always comes back it just never
ends does it always comes back to coke
with you never ends
what is that
oh that's the game Deer pong
silent Keys
holy keys
I don't even know any Christmas songs
on the first day of Christmas Cody gave
to me
a bright something something
gold key nice okay on this what about um
these lines to snort
um
oh yeah yeah there you go
remix
how'd you like the beat boxing
it was fine I actually did you have like
a like a repulsion towards generally I
have a repulsion of Beatboxing yeah
but uh no it was fine this time
they're really good yeah
extremely talented my nose does not feel
good
it like Burns that's one of those peanut
butter cups right there this is my
personal stash but I'll let you have
yeah please thank you
appreciate it that's the type of
diabetic I am I brought my little
chocolates to work you brought these
from home yeah why
do you mean why because we got
chocolates here no mine are better okay
yeah the chocolate's from two Halloweens
ago that's true we do have two-year-old
Tootsie Rolls just a barrel of them over
there but to be fair I think Tootsie
Rolls is like one of the only viable
things in a Armageddon that's true
you know that yeah what are they even
made of people always go on about like a
McDonald's hamburger two years in a jar
still the same yeah dude I think we're
still eating tootsie rolls from 1960. I
think they stopped printing them after
the [ __ ] second war because they're
actually they're not food they're
plastic
yeah
Spitfire airplane engine glue with
chocolate flavorings